لم تشفع عينه خبرته الطويله في اداره
الصراعات وحبك التحالفات فها هو يستيقظ
على امه تتعارك على المبادئ التي لابد
للدول المستقره من الاجماع عليها
[تصفيق]
ولدت اسرائيل متلففه في حكايه التاريخ
والنبوءات
حكايه التاريخ قد تساعد بالهبه الاولى
لكنها لا تصمد طريقا هاديا مع تعاقب
الاجيال
اسرائيل ضميرها اليوم ممزقا بشان القيم
الحاكمه لها
فلم يعودوا مجمعين على مكانه القضاء بل
اقتحمت السياسه قاعات المحاكم بعد محاولات
اليمين المتطرف تعجيم دور المحكمه العليا
يوحدهم العلم لكنهم يختلفون على ما يرمز
له فحتى الجيش وهو العمود الذي قامت عليه
البلاد غدا محل تنازع بعد محاولات تاسيس
اجنحه عسكريه يخشى ان تتمرد على سلطان
الدوله لم يعدوا متفقين على ملامح الحلم
الصهيوني مما جعل التحالفات السياسيه في
غايه الصعوبه وذلك بسبب الهوه الفكريه
المتناميه في المجتمع
كانوا يستطيعون حل الخلاف دون دستور بسبب
وهج البدايات والاتفاق على وجهه المجتمع
لقد تغير كل ذلك ظهرت اسرائيل اكثر تشويا
وتعصبا دينيا فابعد اليسار عن السلطه منذ
عقدين ومات الحديث عن مبادرات السلام
ووعيد الاسرائيليون الى صناديق الاقتراع
خمس مرات منذ 2019
كل ذلك ترجمه لتشقق مجتمعي اعمق فقد ظهر
جيل لم يدرس غير التلمود والتوراه وبجانبه
جيل اخر يسعى ليكون وفيا لروح اسرائيل
التي تاسست عام
اسرائيل التي انشاها رجال قال احدهم ذات
مره انهم لا يؤمنون بالله لكنهم يؤمنون
انه منحهم ارض فلسطين على كل حال
هذا التمزق في احشاء المجتمع تعم قه
البيئه غير المرحبه في الماضي كان نتنياهو
ورفاقه يرممون التمزق الداخلي بمغامرات
خارجيه احيانا لكن كل ذلك تغير ايضا فقد
نبتت في غزه ولبنان مخالب وانياب
فالتشضي الداخلي عميق بل يكاد يكون ترجمه
لفكره المؤرخ الانجليزي من ان المجتمعات
لا تموت لكنها تنتحر
[تصفيق]